[Music]
under tight security indian-administered
Kashmir first Lefton and qivana GC mumu
was sworn in as Prime Minister Narendra
Modi delivered a speech about India's
unity reiha-sama
a sportsman and swimming coach felt
disenfranchised
he says Kashmiri czar bound to be the
losers in the new system jobs Nikhil
thinking until now gosh Wheaties got all
the state jobs but now about 50% of
those would be reserved for minorities
like tell its tribals and a disabled and
on top of that our land was ours but now
anyone can buy it this all began in
August with New Delhi's decision to
revoke the autonomy of
indian-administered Kashmir and split
the region into two union territories
now law enforcement will come directly
under New Delhi but it is the
possibility of sharing land with non
Kashmir ease that has most people
worried here many Kashmiri is also fear
that by putting them with Jammu a Hindu
majority part of the region the Indian
government intends to alter their
demographic the aim they say is to
reduce the numbers of those who seek
autonomy or separation the Supreme Court
of India is yet to give its judgment on
this decision while downtown Serena girl
in indian-administered Kashmir with the
several small protests saw rise the only
area where people regularly held mass
protests but the supporters of the
Indian government say that the lack of
such demonstrations elsewhere in this
region is a sign of the acceptance of
the Indian government's decision however
even if just to alleviate concerns the
Indian government had earlier said that
the region stated in the Indian Union
would be restored at an appropriate time
a mother of two Shahzada meanwhile is
waiting for the day her husband bilal is
released from the prison he was among
thousands arrested during a security
lockdown in August the children wait for
him to return every evening when they
see the fathers of other children come
back home they ask mama has Papa come
back families of thousands of others
who've been arrested are longing to see
their loved ones
has millions of kashmiri is also wait to
see what the future holds under direct
rule from New Delhi archer whare
al-jazeera indian-administered Kashmir